[Applause]
hi good afternoon it's a we have known
our pleasure a pleasure to be here today
when Peter asked me to give this talk he
said it's supposed to be a big picture
talk without too many details but they
see so many experts you know it's going
to be a slightly different talk in the
one I give usually but of course those
who follow us in the last few weeks and
we've been talk a lot about these things
so since I already lost 10 minutes of my
talk I I want essentially to start with
you know a very ambitious question can
we define intelligence in some sense I
mean what is it and I know I'm sure each
one of you has is on the answer or there
are many many answers around I have
something which I've been pursuing for
for many many years which goes back to
what I call the essence not only of
intelligence but maybe of life itself
and it's this notion of making
predictions valuable predictions and so
I'll start with this and then I'll go
back to this quite fascinating story of
neural networks which actually starts
from an attempt to mimic the brain and
eventually grow up into something
completely different and eventually
revolutionized the machine learning
computer science and maybe many other
things the world of the whole and and
the problem with this notion of new
letter that came back and forth over the
last 50 years is that it were just more
puzzles and interesting questions about
why and how they work and I believe that
we are maybe beginning to to find some
answers to some of those questions and
what is really fascinating about those
answers is that they seem to give us
some different perspective not only
about neural networks but about
intelligence again the brain and
that maybe other things so it's a very
ambitious talk and I'm going to squeeze
it even more so so I just want to start
with entertain you with this notion of
valuable predictions so if you really
think define for yourself like I do this
exercises biologists very often they
usually give me either system with
complex metabolism I mean metabolic
exchange of energy and matter with the
world around them so it's obviously not
closed system otherwise they wouldn't be
alive and then the second answer they
usually give you is they reproduce or
replicate themselves and I think that
none of these answer is really
satisfying so I'm looking for something
which is first of all more general I
mean which I really believe will apply
not only to all living things but to all
intelligent things in the most general
sense and also I like to be able to
formulate it mathematically in some
elegant way I mean this is for me an
essential part of any any concept which
is really solid enough to be formulated
through the mathematics and after many
years of thinking about it it's not only
me too many people share this view life
boils down to eventually two to one very
important feature which is the ability
to exploit the predictability of the
environment for their survivability in
something for now in other words to make
valuable predictions if you think about
this lion and deer in this picture which
is really are just another character to
the both life depends on the ability to
know what's going to happen and the one
who will win will stay alive eventually
so predictions is seem to be really an
essential part of this surprising
phenomena that we call intelligence and
and life in general actually if you ask
me where the science of intelligence
begin so I know
I guess different people will put it in
different places in history but I really
believe that it was Jeff smacks of Jeff
Clerk Maxwell in there in around 1871
when he wrote his famous book on the the
nature of hate or the nature of
thermodynamics actually even invented
this this creature before then in some
correspondent he had with a friend of
him he actually thought about what can
violate the second law of thermodynamics
you know that heat always goes from the
hot surface to the cold surface and then
he invented this a funny a creature
which later on was called Maxwell's
demon by Lord Kelvin which was able
somehow without investing any energy
twisted at what he thought at the time
and filter open a little door with
molecules of gas in it and eventually
let the faster molecules move in one
direction and the colder or the slower
multiple molecules to move in another
direction and he said that if such a
creature could exist he could violate
the second law of thermodynamics and
surprisingly I really believe that what
max he'll point down then it was really
the beginning of much mean what we now
understand both and the concept of
information and actually the interaction
between information and the world and
physics and actually we are coming back
to to this notion of Maxwell's demon we
came back history came back several
times since 1871 in a few quite
important steps one of them was little
zealot in in in the 20s who actually
change this this little bit into
something which is now known as the
Dillard engine returns returns
information into mechanical work in some
sense and later on after the notion of
information was formulated a it was
clear that essentially this this story
is really about information and this
demon is in some sense the simplest
possible intelligent creature because he
can change turn essentially of the
patience of the world into something
which violates the the natural flow the
natural flow from order to disorder
which was essentially the second law of
thermodynamics okay so I put it here and
I'll come back to this much later
usually we attribute the notion of
intelligence certainly in the notion of
artificial intelligence to to Alan
Turing who is also of course the father
of computing essentially the father of
the modern computer as we know it today
and he was also the one who coined this
notion of mission or was the first to
really conceived the idea that our brain
our intelligent behavior is nothing more
than a computation and therefore a
computer the way Turing thought about it
the Turing machine could actually be
intelligent and you know in the early
50s this was quite revolutionary but I
actually believed that the second piece
of the story belongs to Claudell was
shun-chan on which more or less at the
same times in in the 40s coined they
formulated this notion of what we now
call information by actually
establishing a theory that actually
should be called the theory of
communication because it was really
putting the fundamental bounds on the
ability to communicate across noisy
channels reliably and by doing this and
as an engineer he actually gave us also
a very crisp and a very elegant
formulation of the notion of information
in general and I'm actually using this I
mean I fell in love a channel like many
others when I first heard about him
early in my undergraduate studies or
even before and since then he is a
theory and the relation between his
theory to both dynamics and artificial
intelligence by the way in this picture
Shannon is is playing with the maze
which actually showed us that even in
the early 50s he was very interested not
only in communication but in intelligent
behavior in control and in solving
puzzles like mazes and so on so Turing
and Shannon are my two
heroes and and I've proceeded in general
the the fathers of more than the more
than age of information I mean
so since essentially the early fifties
you can actually pin down very clearly
to these two people what we now called
the information revolution and the
computation and the digital
communication and it's right quite rare
that everything really focus on on such
on these two individuals we were
actually thinking by the way during the
war on similar problems on both sides of
the ocean how which essentially has to
do with encryption or breaking codes or
actually the notion of hiding language
in something and and so this was the
beginning of what we now call the dream
of AI in the dream of a guy for most of
us that it was formulated in the 50s and
60s and maybe in 70s would essentially
build machines that are as human-like as
possible
really fulfill this dream of Turing this
was a very naive dream and of course the
first thing one of the first thing that
people actually wanted to do we about AI
is to mimic biological intelligence it
was not the thing that a mathematician
computer scientists who are not really
computer scientist at the time engineers
and cybernetics all other all sorts of
other professions they really didn't
think about the brain as the model but
many others thought that this notion of
neurons which are those very special
cells that we have all over our body and
specially in our brain they're
especially in a very interesting way
they form connections among them and
they're from connections among them in
vast numbers I mean on the average in
neuron in our cortex is connected to
about 10,000 other cells and they do it
not because they need any metabolic
oxygen or sugar or anything like this
they get this anyway through the blood
vessels like any other cell you know you
know nobody but they do it for something
which we now can clearly call
information neurons actually connect to
each other
through the transmission of spikes which
is a big electromagnetic activity that a
neuron is is able to generate for about
one millisecond and this is a very
expensive process metabolically I mean
this is something eventually the spikes
in our brain consume fraction a large
fraction of the energy that we need you
know something like 20 or 30 percent of
the energy spent in our body is consumed
on spikes in the brain so the reason why
this is happening is mainly to broadcast
their existence to other neurons around
them I'm here and I know something that
you don't know and essentially they do
it by sending this completely anonymous
said content free spike but because of
the timing of the spark as we understand
it today I'm actually sending
information to everyone and only I am
responding to something in the and if
you are responding to this thing after
we I program probably better than you
and we we now call this particular rule
I mean connect to the cells that
actually perceives you're in their
activity we call this stvp or type spike
dependent plasticity a time different
plasticity and and it's it's essentially
a rule which and you think about it
enhancing the ability to make
predictions because if neurons are
connected to each other I'm connected to
you if you know the answer slightly
earlier than me in class then you
probably know something that I should
know therefore should connect you but if
I am behind you you should look for me
hey I'm free for you you should look for
me and vice versa so the connection is
very symmetric so we know now that
spikes or connection between neurons are
actually found in under in order to
enhance predictability to make the whole
system know much much earlier something
about the future this is not the only
way to think about spikes but that's at
least my way to think what spikes but
one of the other thing that will happen
once we realize that the neurons those
intelligent gates or intelligent cells
essentially all they do is connect to
our
neurons and accumulate the information
in the neurons and then summarize this
knowledge by essentially spiking or not
spiking that the model the formal model
of the neuron came very early already in
the early forties the McCulloch pitts
neuron as we call it today which was
essentially okay I can summarize all
this complex behavior or know as a
neuron is extremely complex but you know
mathematician or those people at the
time modeled it by this very simple gate
so imagine that this is connected to M
inputs in this case n plus 1 inputs and
and those inputs are actually the
activity of other cells and each
connection has a certain way to certain
efficacy which I can connect the note
with w1 to WM whatever so essentially
what with what this neuron this formal
neuron is doing is just a dot product
multiplying these weights by the
activity and then generate a spike or in
other words take the value of this baton
dot product and compare it to some sort
of a threshold function if it's above a
certain threshold fire if it's not don't
fire that's the essence of what we now
call neuron or the formal Nia course
this is a very complicated function it's
highly nonlinear but otherwise it's it's
a very simple function dot product and
non-linearity now the idea of actually
using these things for for artificial
intelligence or pattern recognition is
very old essentially it goes all the way
to Rosen blood from presume not in there
in the 50s who already suggested putting
those neurons in a network in a way
which we now call feed-forward neural
network or not it's early feed-forward
but this is the feed-forward neural
network and and this idea was always so
that said in his book and actually in
his book he already had the notion that
you need many layers
many layers of connections like this so
each neuron is connected to them neurons
above him to the next layer and those
together generate something which at the
end can be the output of a classifier
- out of a pattern on Commission's so
this was this did were the simplest the
simple neuron that was and everybody
thought that you probably need just a
few layers in order to solve our problem
actually mathematical theorems that tell
you that with two hidden layers or one
hidden layer if it's wide enough I can
essentially approximate any function
within some you know technical technical
assumptions which is not that hard so so
many years we actually thought that this
should be enough two layers should
essentially give us everything we want
and Rosenblatt were actually very well
aware that you need many layers but he
didn't really have a clue how to train
those weights I mean change them this
this happen later through all sorts of
ideas that some came from biology some
came from psychology some came from
engineering but eventually we now know
that we need to adjust the ways and some
in some way in order to make this
network useful okay so this were the
optimistic times of the sixties the
early sixties we're really people
believed not only that intelligence is
nothing but building a machine that
mimic us we we also have the mechanisms
we have neural networks we have many
many other pattern recognition and AI
apparatus but with the hopes came the
great disappointment and if you actually
look at what shapes our understanding of
of AI in the 60s and 70s
so I remember for example this book of
habit Dreyfus which is still very
popular by the way what computer can't
do which is actually list in a very
reasonable way
why machines can never behave like an
intelligent way essentially everything
and you know our our our expectations
from artificial intelligence was very
much shaped by Hollywood and they say by
the way I created I mean I think the
most of the disappointment from AI comes
from our expectations through the movies
and it was actually that the the famous
hull in 2001 of Kubrick and that really
created maybe the most the first idea of
vicious efficient
I mean of something that can harm us in
some sense and I think we are still very
much under the oppression of this a very
powerful image but and of course with it
came all sorts of jokes and like this
translation from English to Russian and
back of the Spirit is willing but the
flesh is weak you probably heard about
it or essentially the notion of of
intelligence there was transformed in a
very named way to something we now we
then called expert system and expert
systems were essentially the idea that
if you want to do something intelligent
you should go to an intelligent guy like
your doctor or your your your clever
teacher and simply ask him how how does
he do things and and then for example
ask him how does he diagnose and disease
and he will tell you and I'll program it
to me right and by and this is what we
call them rule based systems and rule
based system where essentially you know
ask someone to explain for example how
do you see or how do you understand
language or how do you prove theorems
and whatever and I will simply program
it for you so obviously this was not
only very naive it was completely wrong
because none of us can even the best
experts cannot explain how they do
things and of course the main problem
with such extra systems that they were
essentially just big look-up tables and
then they they simply were simply a
table of all the possible answers to
some some sort of query or some sort of
but they didn't generalize I mean this
notion of generalization the ability to
do things beyond your sample was not
only not understood it was completely
absent for those machines although of
course a people knew already that you
can't have a what we now call a free
lunch I mean you can't really get
anything beyond your sample without
assuming something about the structure
of your problem and but this is exactly
what people are trying to do for about
20 years from the 60 to the 80s and it
was of course this this led to a lot of
failures and of course things like robot
that could not stand people football
players who play really in a pathetic
way until today
and we still consider its high
intelligence but anyway so so at effect
artificial intelligence is is very far
from what we would like to be but maybe
they're really the domain at turn back
assisting that in the public mind was
1916 97 where a chess a chess game chess
player program deep mind this bleep blew
off of of IBM and won essentially with
some effort the championships in chess I
mean a guy Kasparov at the time right
there isn't I think the most impressive
part about this photograph is not as
Chris farm is sweating actually this is
the beginning of the game I don't know
why but yeah but there is a human there
that needs to move the tools on there so
the computer could actually play chess
very cleverly but he could not move the
tool to pieces okay so it's least not in
the same way that we do and we are very
far from that still so so there was
something clear at least people III
thought hood at that time already the
Train chest is not the right problem or
anything like playing chess is not the
right problem I mean it was clear
clearly a very artificial of the very
clever game but but very structured very
logical and essentially a special
special machine a special purpose
machine like like the blue which has
really no intelligence whatsoever in any
general sense it was simply some sort of
a summary and exhaustive search over
many many moves in many many games
essentially played by human and
eventually it was the memory and the
search power not only the world also
some clever ideas there but this was a
very special machine which was not
generalized to anything else so we had
to go back to the natural problem and
the natural problems were were actually
a simple the simplest one of the least
intelligent one like vision
understanding speech walking without
falling and and so on I mean the thing
that every annual your dog can do very
well
and other and other animals so actually
the whole thing took another very
important turn toward the end of the two
thousand two thousand nine seven eight
nine ten
with these neural networks actually came
back in a very different or slightly
different form instead of just few
layers one two three which were
mathematically provably enough yeah but
actually we knew that they are not
enough in any simple way they they
turned it some type of people or some
stubborn people like Geoff Hinton and
Yun lacunar a few others and then it
simply took it to an extreme in some
sense by adding many many layers not
necessarily very wide layers but some of
them can be wide and essentially trained
them using essentially the same
algorithm we used in the 80s which we
call error back propagation and error
propagation was actually take the
gradients of the error on the training
data and sorry for all of you who knows
older and them actually propagated back
and this error here propagated through
using the chain rule of derivative which
is something not known to some people
the chain of derivative and eventually
and adjust all the weights and the way
we do it today we do it by by an
algorithm which I'm going to analyze it
would in much more detail which we call
stochastic gradient descent and
stochastic gradient descent is
essentially the trick used
computationally in order to propagate
this error efficiently so instead of
actually calculating the gradient of the
error on all the examples I calculated
only on on some of them small pieces of
the examples at a time in order to save
time and there was some intuition which
was basically correct that this noise in
the gradient is actually helping us
somehow what was most people thought at
the time and this was mostly the 80s
that is helping us avoiding local minima
of the error surface now the surprise
was that this thing started to work
surprisingly well I mean essentially
this dupe neural networks took us to an
entirely new era and now when we talk
about about about multikill the deep
learning revolution it's really the
combination of two things first of all
moving from the rule-based system which
will do all that official intelligence
to a machine learning machine learning
means I'm not going to dictate the rules
to the system I'm going to learn the
rules from the data using any type of
algorithm I mean whatever some sort of
optimization algorithm which will
eventually find a good machine that fits
the data but then something have to feed
the data it has to generalize remember
that so it has to be able to make
predictions outside of my date and again
this notion of prediction I mean
predicting the label of unknown data now
machine learning was actually born in
the 80s together by the way with the
revival of deep neural networks it was a
this famous paper of of Les valiant in
1982 together with the paper of john
hopfield on the hopeful memory which is
lists for me really took me into this
field both of them somehow shoulders as
learning and memory and the ability to
make adaptation to the environment is
something not only very elegant and very
fundamental but that we can actually
analyze it mathematically with very
crisp theorems what happens in the late
2000 is that machine learning was
transformed back into these stupid
machines which are essentially just
neurons or formal neurons connected to
each other in many many ways
now this okay so this has a really
interesting interesting ups and down
which I'm not going to get into but we
are now in an up phase of this story
deep neural networks are taking over not
only the industry not only as I said
computer science machine learning
machine vision signal processing machine
translation and natural language
processing computational biology a lot
of fields which were of many very hard
problems which we didn't know how to
address like now protein folding for
example or or a you know language
translation or whatever all of them seem
to be attacked by
actually the same architecture the same
machine many layers of neurons Lee now
this of course of course I'm actually
infinitely many very fascinating
examples this is just generated by
Google in the last year for example
describing what we call a image
understanding I mean giving an image of
these of these two bears and get the
machine right to brown bird sitting on
top of frogs
I mean this is quite amazing ten years
ago and suddenly not twenty years ago
because only dream of AI of this kind
all right or you know a vision speech a
control a natural language understanding
as I said computational biology all of
these things are now attacked very well
by those deep neural networks and
actually this something must have
happened
of course several things happened
between the 80s and the early 2000 one
of them is of course what we now call
the Big Data revolution we are able to
train those things on on millions and
hundreds of millions and sometimes
billions of example because this came
because we have much far for much more
powerful computers much more powerful
internet much more powerful storage and
so on but it's it's also of course the
size of the problem itself who rap it's
not only that they have many more
examples the size of the images the size
of the data became essentially
macroscopic and physical sense I mean we
are talking about millions or hundreds
of millions of inputs to such networks
and essentially if you compare what we
now call deep learning to to other
methods they seem not to saturate in
performance when we keep on training
them they keep on improving whether if
we add data or if you just you know keep
keep on optimizing them and this was a
very of course they do things like
self-driving cars and even you know
robots in surgery they stick their robot
starting to become useful maybe you know
they also generate art I mean I'm not
going to talk too much about it for
example you can train them backward I
mean train show a network the style of
Van Gogh and then ask him to paint an
image in the style of Van Gogh and you
get things like this which you may like
or not but but it's interesting you know
it's and renege
and will essentially tell us that AI
today is just electricity is like
electricity I think this is a little bit
exaggerated but essentially its powers
everything I mean you just connect it to
essentially everything you know from
chemistry to medicine and from
engineering for to to to his history and
you bet and to get it faster stronger
and clever maybe of course the amount of
industry I don't have to say it here in
Berkeley that is associated with this
revolution of deep learning and AI is
amazing but of course for people like me
this was very frustrating very first
thinking because the whole thing was was
looked very much like a black box I mean
in some sense you have inputs you put it
through this incredible connectionist
machine and you get out the answer and
you have absolutely no idea what
happened there I mean essentially this
this black box and many people treated
it like this or still treating it like
this is really that the main obstacle
you know of getting something like the
FDA approval for drugs that are designed
by a neural networks or anything like
this because there is no way I can
actually explain what it does or what it
learns or how how good it is or how bad
it is this was a lot of layers I know
exactly what's going on there but I have
no idea what was actually acquired so
the larger problems are essentially what
really happened what changed so that we
have larger problem wave bigger data we
have faster computers and we have
somewhat better understanding of the
brain this is the weakest part of the
story but there was clearly no
connection between those deep neural
networks in the brain the way we know
today the only maybe vague connection is
that there are many neurons here and
that many neurons here and there but the
architecture the way it is trained the
you know the feed-forward nature without
feedback and so on them many many
different things that biologists
considered completely ridiculous for any
biological brain but is this really so
so I think what we begin to to acquire
today it's not only as I mean it's it's
a the community of a lot of good people
who are thinking about deep neural
networks this is
one of the major puzzles of over the
last 10 years in science I mean why do
these things work so well and what can
we tell you about them I mean okay so of
course we know that there's something
funny happening in those layers and
essentially we take an input let's say
of a dog and it's transformed through
this scrambling connections layer by
layer essentially bits into bits in some
other form and eventually the last layer
is able to give us an answer it's a dog
or it's a cat or whatever how does it
happen and why is this work better than
shallow networks or any other
optimization or good let's optimize the
arrows okay so what I want to tell you
now is something which I've been talking
a lot about in the past weeks here at
Simon but I just want to give you a few
of the ideas that I've been playing with
together with some students which are by
no means that the answer to this puzzle
but they may be we call it opening the
black box maybe we are really starting
to get some idea what going inside those
networks and eventually what as I said
from the beginning the fact that we can
actually understand it mathematically
you can actually have some equations
that describe this process of water and
going in the network may eventually lead
us to a real understanding and
eventually improving and maybe
understand that the bigger picture I
mean what's so special about this multi
parameter systems and why they work
someone okay so this is a quote from
quanta magazine from last September
it's about our paper and and I said
there and you know that there's no need
to be so famous but that the main part
of learning is actually forgetting and
forgetting it's actually obvious I mean
this is completely trivial when you
think about it when you learn something
the most important part and turns out
the hardest part of the learning is not
fitting what you know but learning to
ignore would need to be needed being
known this is the hard part of learning
and and I formulated it through through
an idea which which I call the
information bath
I called many years ago the information
button it which is essentially the
notion that you know that to learn you
need some in some systematic way to
squeeze out the irrelevant components of
your story and leave somehow get out
only the relevant parts in the most
concise way as possible and of course
this bottleneck was inspired some
artists atma quanta so you put the
pixels of a dog in you get the identity
of the door but what actually happens is
so again I apologize for some of you
have seen before the way we actually
treat neural networks is that we met
them back into Shannon's idea of
information and and I'm not thinking
about the simplest possible
plain-vanilla different network which
essentially has some input X which is
very complex and some label Y which is
very simple it can be just one bit or
few bits and eventually I want to
understand how those hidden layers what
happened to them in terms of what I
thought is extracting only the relevant
information about the label and ignoring
the rest and how does it happen using
this to pass stupid stochastic gradient
descent algorithm that those layers
represent all sorts of features the
lower layers if you think about an image
for example a face recognition problem
alter cognition problem the lower layers
usually represent what we call the low
level features like you know edges and
and and colors locally that are very
usually local features and that people
are here at Berkeley are really exposed
to understanding of what happen for
example in v1 in the visual system which
is a very simple mathematical local
transformation and we know simply
because it can't be otherwise then when
you move through a cascade of
representation which are essentially a
Markov chain of each one is the course
version of the previous one then the
higher layers somehow managed to
integrate they do this slowly layer by
layer do this Gestalt thing eventually
they they get the big picture and how
does this happen this is really the
story you want to understand so we knew
that
I mean actually more or less they
speculated that there must be on the
higher layers cells that respond to
faces or respond to eyes or respond to
larger objects this actually not what
really happens in my opinion but the
whole layer the higher layer are
certainly doing some sort of integration
over the local detail and so the
interesting question is how does it
happen and I want to show you a movie
that's against many of you have seen
already so what we did based on on the
intuition that we get from from the
understanding of information it's
actually plotted the network and this
was the first time this was done last
year two years ago we put the layers of
the network on a two-dimensional plan
which I really want you to understand
one of them on the abscissa here is the
information that each layer mutual
information this is Shannon's
information which essentially is the
number of yes/no questions the minimum
number of estriol questions I have to
ask in order to reveal something about
my variable this is what it is so
essentially the number here is
essentially how much information on how
many yes/no questions I have to ask you
know to get what a layer knows about the
input of the problem and on the y-axis
you see the same number I mean
information that a layer has about the
output of the problem the label which I
call Y so of course we should write here
information about the input information
about the output it's much clearer but
for those of you who understand that
this is a quantifiable things twelve
here means twelve bits I mean so
essentially my size of the inputs was
only twelve binary inputs and one here
one bit which means that the answer to
this question is yes or no or a binary
bit binary digit and especially what you
see here in different colors are the
layers of a neural network a very small
neural network they had six layers but
what I measured and how I measure it
doesn't matter at this point we measure
the information that each layer has on
both the input in the output and this
gives us a point in this plane and
eventually we DIF may hundred times and
I put here those 150
of randomly initiated networks and what
you see is the beginning of the training
no training you see the number of epochs
there these are epochs of training and
heat each epoch is essentially recycling
all my examples through all my network
using this back propagation algorithm
essentially taking the gradients over
the examples and adapt all the
connections slowly my small steps by
these stochastic gradient and and when
you train the network you you see this
really fascinating movie so this
fascinating movie and I know that some
of you have seen it many times but it's
alright I've seen it more times mmm
this is this has essentially two phases
one of them the first one is then I go
up and fit my data and the second one is
that I go see so this this happens very
quickly you know close to 300 episodes
of day of cycling the example so all the
all the layers essentially climb up and
eventually learn the data to some extent
notice that they added the information
about the input and added information
about the output but this is not the end
of the story this is essentially where
my training error my error on the
training data which is a small tiny
fraction of the self training images of
someone I get a few hundred or maybe a
few thousand images of someone I need to
generalize to essentially an infinite
number of images so this is a tiny part
of the data at this point I already fit
the error of pretty well not completely
but pretty well but then something
completely different start to happen and
eventually I start to do this very slow
look at the number of a proxy it's very
slow compared to the previous set
computers and phrases essentially it
goes up improving the information about
about the label when it gets to one I
predict the label perfectly but at the
same time essentially all the layers
move to the left and moving to the left
here means that they forgot information
about the
now this was for me a very revealing
picture we didn't expect this to be so
nice there are many many technical
things to answer but I'm not going to do
it here why is that why it looks like
this and why behave like this but this
this message was essentially the essence
of the story which can be summarized in
this particular picture if you look at
the information about the input and
information about the output the layers
do this this is some sort of an x-ray
they very quickly move from A to C which
is essentially memorizing your training
data but then they vary which is what we
thought learning is all about memorizing
what you're told
no the real part of the landing starts
when you move from C to E and this C to
E is improving your prediction by
essentially forgetting the irrelevant
part of the story now you see that this
something like this happens to all the
layers if you measure correctly the
information so there's something some
conspiracy of something very nice that
happens in the layers themselves they
actually help the last layer which is
the important one the one from which I'm
actually making the prediction the last
layer converge faster or forget faster
the irrelevant things and they forget
because because sometimes we call data
processing inequality because
essentially a layer cannot remember
something which the previous layer
already forgot I mean ok that's that's
what it means
so essentially if the lower layers move
to the left they push forward the higher
layers as well
so this forgetting process is actually
very very important for the learning so
the way we thought about it and these
are the two students who actually worked
on it during last part usually if nobody
slovsky's reveals if we actually saw
that about it some sort of a bottleneck
you know it looks very much like an
autoencoder
so essentially the information goes and
I'm squeezing all the information
through this stochastic process through
very narrow a layer which essentially
must remember only the important when it
has to mean I am forced to remember only
the important things I'm eventually
going to
generalize well and we understand it
very well so for example you can think
about these two characters they found on
the Internet
this sketch for example I remember in
couture recognizing kit this has a lot
of irrelevant details which are very
nice like the colors of the hair it's
and the mouse which is very or not and
so on but of course what I really need
to know about the cat is is more or less
like this character which is a lot less
information if I try to remember every
detail
I'm not going to generalize we know this
very well but but this this disability
to distinguish between the relevant and
irrelevant is something which somehow
this particular algorithm with this
particular architecture is doing very
well so how does this happen
essentially again this is another
important picture in my story it all
happens due to noise and this is very
surprised so essentially what you see
here are the gradient of the error on
the training data as they look through
the layers so the different layers are
in different colors here and this again
is a specific network but it's not
really important and what you see at the
mean and the standard deviation of those
gradients where the standard deviation
of the noise is the part of the gradient
is not because I add noise to the data
it's because the examples are slightly
different from each other and this noise
is actually due to the fact that I'm
training my network on pieces of the
data and those pieces of the data have
slightly different details especially
slightly different irrelevant detail
program you see your face some of them
here have one person in the background
another have another pattern of
background or no person in the
background the background is changing
much faster than the object itself and
eventually these are these fluctuations
in the background which poses the
network to learn better by essentially
averaging and here again comes the fact
that we are talking about very large
problems now so this is a very high
dimension and those average trajectories
those random walks that is are done by
these noisy
of the data these random jobs eventually
average something quite interesting the
network remember better the important
things and the signal-to-noise ratio or
the details of the non important things
is slowly decaying and when it's slowly
decaying all those layers move to the
left so this compression is essentially
through this noisy process which is not
really noise this is some sort of
unsupervised learning is the fact that
the background of the irrelevant details
of my pattern vary a lot and this
variance is generating a diffusion so
noise is essentially pushing the problem
to where it is now we have only very few
minutes so what I want to tell you first
of all this observation it's not even a
theory I mean this is observation that
something happens dude
during this noisy part of the training
which is very very important let us of
course to a mathematical understanding
of a few quite important facts for
example the benefit of the hidden layers
is not because this hidden neural
networks can express very complicated
functions as some people say
no it's course they can but they can
express very complicated function when
they are much chiller
they what happens here is completely
dynamical this is where my physics head
comes in so essentially I know that this
stochastic process this diffusion
process is faster when it spread over
all those layers in parallel rather than
happens at one so essentially if the
dynamics of this slow process of
forgetting which is shared and enhanced
by the fact that there are many layers
and what you see here if you just look
at the color is the number of epochs you
see that the same problem with one or
two hidden layers takes much longer time
than training it with a lot of layers so
this is one fascinating thing that come
out of it the other thing that's come
out of it we have a mathematical
understanding of what is the optimal
place in this plan that any algorithm
can be so essentially remove the theory
of learning versus I'm trying to it's
not very easy from what we now we used
to
for distribution independent probably
approximately correct balance some of
you may know about it which essentially
tell us
I want a machine that learns every
problem universally good rather than
that I'm telling you I want a problem
dependent bound which is machining
depend I want to know what is the best
that can be done with this data by any
machine and and therefore if this is
indeed the right bound it also tells me
how the brain can learn biology I can do
it on the same data not specific on the
machine and this particular bound is
something we know how to calculate for
many years it has a lot of mathematical
interesting problem physical interesting
problem which I believe it give us
Turner and this correspondence within
the stochastic dynamic stochastic
gradient descent of the author of the
training and this particular information
theoretic problem gives us a very
powerful tool of understanding both the
structure of the layers where they end
up what the what the layers represent
what the weights represent what do they
encode and so on and so forth and many
many interesting problems commodity now
I want to go back to the brain just for
a second call that promising so this I'm
right and we are at the beginning of
some and some understanding of why this
deep neural networks over and the story
is essentially about using noise in a
clever way or actually use the fact that
it's huge problem it's very large
problem so this asymptotic sub
information theory which is also that's
the protocol statistical physics going
is helping us so essentially I got rid
of the dependence on the architecture on
the machine itself so this type of
theory must tell me something about the
brain and actually now when we go back
to the brain we realize that the only
the main thing that the brain does is
again prediction and this story of
prediction homage clever predictions is
very nicely very neatly in a tie with
the story of information
so essentially what the brain is doing
is extracting the irrelevant information
from its past sensory inputs in a
valuable way for the future actions
that's what we thought I believe but
this particular sentence has a lot of
mathematic
behind it which I can explore and
develop and I can tell you for example
how we appreciate out by essentially
generating predictions on why we enjoy
music or for example how language
evolves and this is just just another
just a a little propaganda for a new
paper of Naga on the evolution of
language done here at Berkeley and
evolution of color names-- in this case
and so on so forth especially we know
that the brain is about storing
information what we call the perception
and action cycles in multiple time
scales taking information from the
sensory perception and apply it in a
predictive mode and the balance of
information flowing this cycle I believe
is telling us the very big very
interesting story about how the brain
what the brain really does from far away
if you manage to get out of the details
all right there are many more things to
say I have to finish I just want to tell
you that I believe yet that we are
really living in a fascinating period
because I think that many many branches
of science are all essentially you know
funneling into these computer science
issues so the notion of computation
efficient computation efficient
optimization the understanding of the
connection team dynamics and information
which is essentially between computation
information is really a getting very
close to biology getting very close to
the most important and interesting
questions in our life today and I'm very
happy to to be there and to be part of
it and I have to finish so thank you
very much
[Applause]
you